[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and with season 2 of my
ear academia ending we thought that it
would be a good idea to make a video
where we talk about all of the new
characters that will be appearing in the
upcoming third season of my hero
academia we will be explaining who they
are and what their quirks are right here
in one place but while I will be talking
about their background and powers I will
do my best to avoid plot spoilers this
means that I will explain who they are
without telling you what happens to them
in the story some of these characters
were briefly teased in season 2 already
and season 3 will introduce us to new
villains new top ranked Pro heroes new
students from other schools and more so
if you can't wait to find out who these
people are and how their quirks work
you've come to the right place if you
enjoyed this type of video and want to
see more videos like it be sure to Texas
smash that like button to let me know we
have a lot of mine hero academia videos
already on the channel and many more are
on the way so if you're new don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell and if you want to help us decide
what type of videos we should make next
be sure to follow us on twitter at anime
uproar because we'll be creating polls
for you guys to vote on what types of
videos you want to see here on the
channel and without further ado let's
get into it I believe that my hero
academia season 3 is definitely going to
cover the school trip arc and the
hideout radar and I potentially think
that if it's a full season it will also
cover the hero license exam arc so
starting things off at the very
beginning of the school trip arc we meet
the pussycats
a pro hero team specializing in mountain
rescue this team is made up of four
members including mandalay whose real
name is shima Sasaki the name of her
quirk is telepath it's type is emitter
and it works at long range her quirk
enables Mandalay to communicate with
several people at one time through
telepathy but since the people she is
communicating with are not telepaths
they are able to receive information
from her but they cannot respond
she scores up five out of five and
cooperativeness according to the my hero
academia character book and this makes
sense since her quirk is perfect for a
team player
did I say perfect because I meant
perfect to Kenneth's [ __ ] okay I'm
moving on aside from her quirk Mandalay
is also very athletic which makes her
effective in hand-to-hand combat then we
have pixie Bob her real name is if you
cool - chica hua and she's an energetic
and attractive woman but due to the fact
that she is 31 years old and still not
married she is shown to be actively
looking for a male suitor and she is not
above flirting with mail you a students
like Deku and Todoroki the name of her
quark is earth flow its type is emitter
and it works at long range her quirk
enables pixie Bob to control and reshape
the earth around her and use it as both
a tool and a weapon in combat I guess
you can say that she is basically an
earthbender next is rag doll real name
Tomoko Shillito Kolb
she is known for being extremely
energetic and she was at one point
ranked as the number 32 bro hero the
name of her quirk is Serge its type is
emitter and it is target based with the
help of her quirk rag doll is able to
conduct surveillance on up to 100 people
at a time and she can sense both their
current location and their potential
weaknesses and the final member of the
Pussycats is Tiger he is the only male
member of the group and he is also the
only one who takes his hero name from a
wild cat species Mandalay pixie Bob and
rag doll are all species of house cats
Tiger is strict and tough and he
believes that everyone including the
young UA students must undergo rigorous
training if they want to become real
heroes the name of his quirk is Playa
body essentially meaning pliable body
its typist transformation and it works
at close range as a result of his quirk
Tiger could stretch his body in
impossible ways which allows him to get
through extremely narrow and cramped
spots and this comes in handy with the
rescue missions that he is often
involved with even though his body is
pliable Tiger is still physically strong
and he scores a 5 out of 5 in power
according to the mine hero academia
carrot
during the school trip arc we also meet
Kota a five year old boy who is the
nephew of Pussycat member Mandalay kotas
parents were a husband-and-wife pro-hero
team known as water horse
they both had water type quirks and they
were killed in action while fighting to
protect innocent civilians from a
powerful village although they lost
their lives they managed to save the
civilians by injuring the villain to the
point that he was unable to continue his
attack even though kotas parents are
celebrated as heroes he was deeply
affected by their deaths he feels that
his parents abandon him by choosing to
risk their lives as pro heroes instead
of just being normal parents and as a
result Kota hates quirks and the current
society in which pro heroes and villains
use their quirks to pointlessly fight
each other
at first he is very cynical and even
aggressive towards the UA students but
after dec who rescues him from a villain
he is grateful to deku for helping him
even though the two of them barely knew
each other Kota is shown to have a water
based quirk just like his parents but we
only get to see a very brief glimpse of
it and now let's jump into the villain
so we'll also play a major role in the
school trip arc
first we have Gidon a broker and scout
who looks for new villains to join the
League of villains we saw a glimpse of
him in season 2 and his primary concern
is making a profit and he has little
interest in the well-being of other
people he is known for always smoking a
cigarette and having a smirk on his face
the nature of his quirk is still unknown
to us but we do know that ena has
exceptional business savvy and close
connections to the criminal underworld
and now we have to talk about the
Vanguard action squad a group of 10 and
new recruits affiliated with the League
of villains who are considered to be an
elite villain fighting force we do catch
some glimpses of these villains in
season 2 and first we have dobby after
the public learned about stain and his
philosophy dobby was one of the people
who was inspired to follow in staines
footsteps and finish what stain had
started he joined the league of villains
in the mistaken belief that stain was
affiliated with them Dobby has a very
interesting appearance as large portions
of his skin are dark purple and seemed
to be sold
rest of his body with stitches which
definitely reminds me of the
Frankenstein monster Dobby has a
fire-based quirk which allows him to
generate powerful dark flames that he
can then use to destroy his enemy his
chosen villain named Dobby means
cremation in Japanese which makes sense
when we consider his deadly fire based
work but interestingly enough he refuses
to reveal his real name and I wonder if
there is a good reason for that then we
have he Miko boga just like Dobby
Tolga joined the League of villains in
order to follow in the footsteps of her
idol stain or stain II as she calls him
although she claims that her goal is to
make the world a better place in the way
that stain had wanted to she exhibits
signs of being mentally unstable the
name of her quirk is transform and the
type is obviously transformation togas
quirk allows her to change her
appearance in order to look and sound
like a completely different person if
she is able to consume enough of that
person's blood on top of that if she
holds her breath and clears her mind she
can actually appear invisible to her
opponents during a battle she carries a
pocket knife that allows her to drain
the blood of her opponents so that she
can use her quirk and she also carries a
blood draining machine on her back the
lesser drained the blood quickly she
isn't very strong physically her power
rank is only one out of five but she has
excellent reflexes and makes up for what
she lacks in power with her agility
speed and of course stealth next is a
villain known as mustard of teen villain
with a unique appearance mustard is
known for wearing a school uniform along
with a gas mask and green army helmet on
top of his quirk he also uses a revolver
pistol as a weapon and he isn't afraid
to use it
his quirk is referred to as sleep gas
its type is emitter and it works at long
range this quirk enables mustard to
create gas that puts people to sleep he
is able to control the gas and you can
also sense the movements of anyone who
is located inside the zone where the gas
has spread as he is not immune to the
effects of his own quirk mustard has to
wear a gas mask when
he is using it his name is most likely a
reference to mustard gas a deadly
chemical weapon first used by the German
army in World War one then we have twice
twice his real name is Jean booba
Guevara and he is another villain who
exhibits signs of mental instability
when he isn't wearing his villain
costume he is shown to have an identity
crisis and seems to lose control of
himself until he puts the mask on which
calms him down the name of his quirk is
double its type is eMeter and it works
on contact this quirk enables twice to
create clones of himself or others by
touching them he previously used this
power to clone himself over and over
again in order to create an army of
clones which he then used to help him
finish various tasks but because each
clone retains the same personality as
the original the clones could not
determine who was the real twice and
they turned on each other at this point
twice isn't even sure if he is the
original or if he is simply one of his
own clones which results in his identity
crisis when one of the clones he creates
with his quirk is destroyed it dissolves
into a dark liquid next is spinner this
villain has a distinctly reptilian
appearance and the face of a lizard as
yet another villain who was greatly
inspired by stain spinners masks and
clothing are designed to copy what
stained himself wore the most
interesting part about him is his
strange weapon which is a giant
makeshift sword made up of all sorts of
different smaller blades despite how big
and heavy it is spinner is able to use
the sword with exceptional speed which
makes us think that maybe his quirk
could be related to superhuman reptilian
strength and then we come to muscular as
his name suggests muscular is a
muscle-bound village he has a
distinctive scar on his face and a
prosthetic eye he is sadistic and
violent and he takes pleasure in killing
people including innocent civilians
muscular was the villain who killed
kotas parents
was during his battle with them that he
lost his eye muscular scores a five out
of five for both power and speed so he
has a really strong quirk but he scores
only a one out of five in intelligence
the name of his quirk is muscle
augmentation its type is transformation
and it works at close range this quirk
enables muscular to transform or augment
his muscle fibers in order to become
both stronger and faster
his quirk is incredibly powerful when it
comes to physical strength it allows him
to smash rocks to bits and he was even
able to take the force of deck whose
100% Detroit smashed without suffering
much damage up next is magnet real name
Kenji Hickey XI Magna has long red hair
large lips and he is known for his
ruthlessness and cruelty he was a
hardened criminal who committed multiple
robberies and murders before joining the
league of villains the name of his
Quercus magnetism and it enables magnet
to magnetize everyone within 4 and 1/2
meters of where he is standing he uses
the magnetic properties of his quirk to
manipulate the movement of his opponents
either their entire body or a specific
part of their body women and men have
different magnetic poles according to
the rules of this work and if he
magnetizes two people of the same gender
magna will actually make them repel each
other with great force magnet is not
able to use his quirk on himself but
even without his quirk magnet is
extremely skilled in hand-to-hand combat
then we have mr. compress allegedly one
of the most intelligent villains in the
world mr. compress is a former
entertainer I assumed that he was a
magician or illusionist of some sort
judging by his cool outfit and he also
has a very interesting quirk the name of
his quirk is compressed it's type is
emitter and it works on contact this
quirk enables mr. compress to literally
shrink or compress everything within a
certain physical zone into a small
marble mr. compress can trap people
inside these marbles and render them
powerless and he is also able to quick
turn everything inside the marble back
to its normal size when he wants to do
it as long as he can touch his target he
can shrink and trap them inside the
marble and he can even make himself
smaller for short periods of time in
order to dodge attacks from opponents on
top of his quirk he is exceptional
acrobatic skills speed and intellect and
the final member of the Vanguard action
squad is moon fish easily the creepiest
villain out there moon fish apparently
escaped from death row and now wears SMM
here while his mouth remains forced open
with metal clamps he seems to be
obsessed with meat and flesh especially
the flesh of his opponents his quirk has
been referred to as dental manipulation
and essentially it allows him to
transform his teeth into extremely
strong and sharp blades then he can use
both to attack and also to help him move
out of the way of oncoming attacks and I
will also say that during the school
trip art we see another know move with
the Vanguard action squad this know
appears to have a transformation type
quirk similar to metal shoji that allows
the creature to grow multiple arms and
fill them with deadly weapons such as
drills and chainsaw and after the school
trip arc we jumped right into the
hideout raid arc where we finally learn
more about all four one of the
mastermind behind the league of villains
all for one was once the most powerful
villain in all of Japan and all mites
greatest enemy he is known for wearing a
mask that is reminiscent of Darth Vader
and beneath the mask he appears to have
a severely scarred and disfigured face
in addition he has breathing tubes that
can be seen sticking out of his neck
implying that he was gravely injured at
some point in his life which is also
very much like Darth Vader all for once
quirk is also called all-4-one
and it allows its user to steal the
quirks of others and use them for
himself on top of that all-4-one also
allows its user to transfer the stolen
works on to other people the unfortunate
individuals who have their quirks stolen
by all-4-one are sometimes left in a
veggie
state of state similar to a coma that is
pretty brutal in itself but in addition
to that some people who receive a stolen
quark as a result of Oh for one are
unable to handle them and they
themselves become a mindless creatures
capable of nothing but following orders
just like no and even more than that
all-4-one can combine multiple stolen
works in one person in order to create
more powerful super Kirk's
that never would have occurred naturally
we know that one for all is a quark that
is passed on from one person to the next
so that they can use it to help others
but all for one seems to be the opposite
of that because it brings multiple
quirks together in one person so that
all of those quirks are working for the
benefit of that single individual and of
course the epic clash between one for
all and all for one will be an important
theme throughout season 3 and I
personally can't wait to see it animated
during the hideout radar we are also
introduced to some new pro heroes
including the number tenth ranked pro
hero gang Orca real name coogo Sokka
Mota his work makes him a cross between
a man and an orca whale the nameless
quark is killer whale its type is mutant
and it works at close range as a result
of his work gang Orca can use the powers
from a killer whale he is large strong
an excellent swimmer and he can produce
a sound wave that paralyzes his
opponents his weakness is that being
part marine animal makes him prone to
dehydration when he is not in water so
he always carries water with him in case
he needs to pour it on himself to
prevent dehydration gang Orca is based
on a character called Sokka Mata from
Kohei maurico she's earlier manga series
called Omega Doki zu in this earlier
manga zoo animals can take on a humanoid
form and another my hero academia
character who was inspired by a
character in Omaha Kazu is the snake
hero who above me then we have the
number five ranked pro hero headshot
real name Shinya kami Hara he kind of
looks like a modern-day ninja the name
of his quirk is Fulda body it's type is
transfer
and it works at close range this quirk
enables edge shock to fold and stretch
his body which gives him great stealth
and agility this quirk is similar to
Tigers fly a buddy quirk
however headshot is able to transform
his body faster than the speed of sound
which makes him much faster than Tiger
headshot is even able to twist and turn
his body into a sharp weapon and strike
his opponents before they even see him
coming next we have Nana Shimura
introduced as a memory from all mites
past Nana was a friend of Gran Torino
and all mites former mentor she was the
seventh user of the transferable twork
known as one for all Nana was known for
her commitment to justice and for always
doing her best to help others with a
smile on her face but sadly some time
after transferring her quark on to all
Mike she was murdered by the mastermind
behind the league of villains when she
had one for all just like all might she
had superhuman strength speed agility
and reflexes we can assume that along
with one for all Nana Shimura had a
second work but we have no idea what
type of work it was also in season three
we will likely get glimpses of some of
the UA students parents this includes
Jiro's dad who is a rock star and baku
goes mom and dad by the way baku goes
mom seems like an even bigger badass
than baku go now season 3 might end
after the hideout ray dark but it might
also go into the hero license exam mark
where we get to meet characters from
other Japanese hero schools we will meet
Emmy fuku kado aka miss joke the smile
hero a teacher at katsu bhutesu Academy
miss joke is a young pro hero with a
great sense of humor and a cheerful
attitude she has known Eraserhead for a
long time they used to work near each
other and miss jokes seems to enjoy
flirting with him even though he doesn't
return her flirtatiousness the name of
her quirk is outburst its type is
emitter and it is said to have the
ability to force people around her to
laugh to the point that they can no
longer control themselves and so she can
literally paralyzed villains with
laughter when I first read about her
quirk in Chapter 103 I couldn't help but
think of the
Joker from Batman and his laughing gas
that he uses as a weapon
also from katsu bhutesu Academy we have
Yeol Shindo a sly and determined
second-year student with a powerful
quirk the name of his quirk is shake its
type is emitter and it works at long
range as a result of his quirk Shindo
can generate powerful earthquakes when
he makes contact with the ground and he
is generally able to control the
intensity of the quake if he uses too
much power at once he may experience
some physical blowback from the
aftershocks during this same arc we also
meet a number of students from sheikah -
hi another well-known hero school first
we have a messiah she whose hero name is
Gale ashika - hi first year student he
actually took part in the UA entrance
exam with Todoroki and Deku even though
he performed really well and finished
the exam just ahead of Todoroki he
decided to decline the offer of
admission and go to chicka - hi instead
Inessa is a high-energy guy and he seems
to believe that true heroes have a fiery
spirit that it still sphere into
villains and inspires everyone around
them in this way he reminds me of coming
up from Gurren Lagann my favorite anime
character of all time as a child
enos I used to admire pro-hero and ever
but after he tried to get endeavours
autograph and the hero simply brushed
him aside and told him to stay out of
his way Inessa felt that this was not
the type of spirit that a true hero
would have after the younger Todoroki
gave him a similar response when he
tried to congratulate him during the UAE
entrance exam
Inessa started to resent both the father
and the son Inasa has a wind based
emitter type quirk that works at long
range he can create and control wind and
he has demonstrated a great deal of
precision with his power he can use the
wind to launch himself at faster speeds
and to create powerful offensive attacks
like tornadoes during the first round of
the hero license exam he was able to
eliminate 120 rivals at once which
speaks to his incredible power next we
have kami another first-year student and
chica - hi we first meet her kind of
there
the hero license exam argh I can't say
much about her and her quirk without
spoiling the flawed but I will say that
her appearance in the manga is very
interesting and memorable
next is Seiji Sakura a second year she
Kazu High student Seiji has an inflated
sense of pride and self-worth and he
tends to look down on others especially
the students from other schools he has a
very strange meat processing quirk
currently referred to as meatball which
is a transformation type quirk that
works at long range this work allows
Seiji to control and alter human flesh
such as turning the bodies of rival
students into motionless balls of meat
he can also break off his own body parts
and control them separately from his
body in chapter 107 we see that his
quirk allows him to effectively take on
a large number of opponents at once his
one known weakness is that if he suffers
enough damage the effects of his quirk
will wear off and the opponent's he
mobilized up to that point using his
work will become mobile again finally we
have Nagamasa Mora second-year sheikah -
student and class rep for his class
Mona's body is entirely covered in hair
and the first thing I thought when I saw
this guy was that he must be inspired by
cousin it from the Addams Family Mora
seems to be the calm and rational one
out of the sheikah sugru and he acts in
a civil and polite way towards the UA
students his mutant type long range
quirk allows him to extend his hair in
all directions which enables him to use
the hair as a weapon against multiple
opponents at once and finally at the
very end of season 3 I think that we may
be introduced at least briefly to the
next major villain so in case we do I
will talk about him here first
introduced at the end of chapter 115
overhaul is the leader of the eight
precepts of death his real name is Chi
Saki
he hates dirty places any things that
everyone around him is sick and filthy
his goal is to become the undisputed
ruler of the criminal underworld and he
doesn't hesitate to destroy anyone who
stands in his way
be they heroes or villains the name of
his quirk is overhaul the type is
Manor and it works on contact his cleric
allows overhaul to disassemble anything
he touches only to reassemble it again
later if he chooses to when he uses it
against an opponent the opponent will
experience incredible pain and become
incapacitated but their body parts will
later be reassembled with all of their
past injuries and illnesses cured using
his quirk appears to take a physical
toll on overhaul he develops a rash and
itching which might feed into his
irrational fear of illnesses and that is
it all of the characters double appear
in mine hero academia season 3 explained
based on the information that we have so
far if you made it this far into the
video first of all thank you so much
because I know it's long but I hope that
it's gonna be useful for you to have all
of these season 3 characters in one
place if you want to let me know that
you made it this far please drop a
hashtag season 3 hype in the comments if
you enjoyed this type of video and want
to see more be sure to Texas smash that
like button to let me know we have many
my hero academia videos on the channel
already and many more are on the way so
if you are new don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell as always
thank you so much for watching and until
next time see us space Cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]